eeuu está haciendo grandes progresos en
la lucha contra el kobe 19 sin embargo
el presidente joe biden se ha visto
forzado a reconocer con decepción que el
país no alcanzará su objetivo de
vacunación
todos sabemos que han emergido potentes
variantes como la variante delta por
favor si no ha sido vacunado a sol haz
lo ahora por ti mismo por tus seres
queridos por tu comunidad y por tu país
guild country en mayo by the end se
marcó una meta que el 70% de los
estadounidenses recibiera al menos una
dosis de la vacuna para el 4 de julio en
realidad sólo consiguieron llegar al 67
por ciento bardem también quería tener
160 millones de adultos totalmente
vacunados pero se quedó a falta de 3
millones y mejorar esas cifras podría
ser una difícil batalla una encuesta
reciente del washington post ya y vice
muestra una fuerte división política en
torno a la vacuna el 86% de los
demócratas han recibido al menos una
dosis entre los republicanos sólo el 45
por ciento y mientras el 6 por ciento de
los demócratas afirma que no recibiría
la vacuna
entre los republicanos el número
asciende al 47% oficiales en estados
republicanos como alabama arkansas y
west virginia están instando a sus
votantes a vacunarse muchos de los
indecisos alegan el rápido desarrollo de
las vacunas la derecha política por su
parte se inclina más por creer que el
gobierno y los medios exageran el riesgo
de la variante delta eeuu suman más de
600.000 muertes por kobe y 19 más de 200
estadounidenses siguen muriendo
diariamente el inmunólogo más importante
del país el doctor anthony fauci dice
que más del 99 por ciento de esas
muertes son de personas sin vacunar